يوم اخر واضراب اخر امر بات اعتياديا في
اليوميات البريطانيه هذه المره تمثل اضراب
قطاعا شديد الحساسيه مرفق الاسعاف ستيف
جونسون مصعب مخضرم شرح لنا اسبابه
للاشتراك في الاضراب
وان كان هذا هو السبب الرئيسي لكن ايضا
بات لدينا نقصون فادح في العاملين
نقابه
تنفي اكبرها تهامه الحكومه لها بتعريض
حياه الناس للخطر والتقاعد عن الترتيب
الجيد لتفادي تعطل الخدمات في اثناء
الاضراب تقول النقابات الثلاثه ان عرض
الحكومه لزياده الاجور يعني هم عن عدم
تقدير لهم بعد نحو عقد من تجميد الاجور
وفي ايونه توحش فيها غلاء الاسعار
وزير الصحه البريطانيا رفض تعليق على
مطالب المطربين وقال انه يركز الان على
اجراءات الطوارئ لتعويض النقص ابراز وهذه
الاجراءات استخدامه جنود القوات المسلحه
فينا المطربين اجراء لقد انتقادات من
اطراف المعارضه قطاع الصحه ومرفق الاسعاف
في بريطانيا يلقاني دعما كبيرا في الشارع
قدموا لنا الكثير من الخدمات سندوا الناس
خلال جائتكورونا لابد ان لديهم اسبابهم
للاضراب
اضراب المسافرين جاء غداه يوم ثان من اكبر
اضراب لطواقم التمريض في تاريخ بريطانيا
وجاء كلاهما تزامنا مع اضرابات متكرره في
قطاعات عده توازيا وتتاليه حتى باتت
الاضرابات تهدد بافساد موسم الاعياد الاول
المسموح فيه بالسفر دون قيود في ثلاثه
اعوام بسبب جائع كورونا
بدخول طواقم الاسعاف على خط الاضرابات
تتعمق المشاكل التي تعصف بالقطاع الصحي في
بريطانيا سيناريو يحذر كثيرون حتى من داخل
حزب المحافظين من خطورته على المواطن
المثقلي باعباء التضخم القاسيه وعلى شعبيه
الحزب الحاكم في البلاد منذ ثني 10 عاما
اسعد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن